[Music]
stanford university the guest speaker
for today is bill crowl we'll be
discussing network and information
security reflecting on the past with
bill's wealth of experiences ranging
from the nsa to the private sector and
then also the look ahead in terms of
future implications on network and
information security so bill crowl has
had a very long and illustrious career
in the security realm he was former
deputy director of the nsa appointed by
president clinton and held in this role
of deputy director of the highest
ranking position for a civilian in the
agency he also served on a number of
different government roles in terms of
the president's export council he was
also on the senior advisory group as its
chairman for the dni the director of
national intelligence for the u.s as
well as on the science and technology
advisory board for dhs department of
homeland security his background in the
private sector rivals that within the
public sector so he was former ceo and
president of sailing corporation which
was a public company prior to its
acquisition by safenet he was also
chairman and board director of a number
of companies that got acquired whether
it was by hp cisco boeing and has
invested in a number of cyber security
companies so bill for today's session
want to touch upon some highlights from
your background and various uh national
security projects that you've worked on
as well as then some topics related to
current security issues that we face and
some of the key attack vectors uh that
are important and then finally some
other global implications and journal
topics in terms of security with iot
global implications implications of
quantum computing on security and just a
few other topics that students have
expressed interest in covering so thanks
for taking the time and we'll go ahead
and get started so during your time at
the nsa around 1943 until 1980 there was
a project called the verona project at
nsa and for the class that was a
counterintelligence program designed to
decrypt messages transmitted by the
intelligence agencies of the soviet
union such as kgb gru can you share with
the class what your role was in that
project and just provide as much as you
can of a brief overview of some of the
challenges that were faced in developing
that program i'd be happy to bernstein
and first i'll start by saying i wasn't
there at 1943. so you have to understand
that i came into the game much later
that project was started in 1943 during
world war ii
it was a very controversial project and
therefore it became a what's called a
green door project no one could get in
unless they were specifically cleared
for it it was jointly done with the fbi
uh nsa and it was directed against uh
soviet intelligence it's a success story
beyond belief and i had
three things that i managed to
do as a part of that program i came into
it in the mid 70s it had been in exist i
actually in 1973 it had been in
existence in 43 in 1948 it produced its
first
decrypt of kgb communications
and that decrypt i actually remember it
quite well the words start out that
antenna's wife antenna was a cover name
for a soviet agent and tennis wife ethel
aged 32
has two sons
helps her husband in his work and has
been quite
effective in
dealing with our mission
meaning the soviet mission that was
julius and rosenberg
that's who the message was about and of
course the famous rosenberg case was
decided by information that came from
that message
all in all 200 agents were identified by
the time i came into the program about
60 of them had either been neutralized
in terms of they left the united states
they went back to the soviet union or
or they went elsewhere in the world one
of them went to the uk and was a
professor at cambridge my job my second
job besides supervising the project when
i came on board was to determine just
how long this should run
i mean how many years were we going to
actually try and break
messages that
only dated from 1943 to 1948
and i made a determination that it would
continue until about 1980 when all of
the agents that were identified
would been would have been too old or
too displaced from the soviet mission
that they
wouldn't be worthy targets for u.s
counterintelligence and the third part
that i played was that i convinced the
director well actually the director cia
and senator daniel moynihan
that we should honor the people who
worked on that project for more than 30
years
and so we had a ceremony at cia in which
we unveiled to the american public
that the
project had been successful if you go on
the nsa.gov
website you
you search by name you will find a
speech that i gave in the cia
headquarters to the public and to the
40 or so people who had worked on the
project that were still alive
and you can find out a lot of facts
about the project
thanks for sharing that bill so you
weren't at that essay in 1943 but you
were there when you're director of
deputy director of operations from 1991
to 1994 and one of the projects you were
in charge of was running its core
signals intelligence missions i know
this was one of the five groups that was
under director john mcconnell based on
the structure of the organization at the
time could you discuss with the class
the field of signals intelligence and
why
it was an important area
yeah
signals intelligence is the intercept of
radio communications in that date
because the internet wasn't really in
existence yet was a couple more years
three more years before it
came into existence but it's the
intercept of radio communications of
foreign nations in order to produce
intelligence
and it included military intelligence
that is
information that was very critical
during wartime the communications of
military forces as they moved around you
probably read stories about
world war ii and the war with the
japanese in which we won the battles of
coral sea and midway by virtue of having
intercepted their
their war plans for those two battles
there were a lot of successes through
the years
in intercepting communications
diplomatic communications military
communications
and strategic communications that is the
communications of leadersh leaders and
leadership and negotiations being
carried on around the world the i'd say
the most important thing that happened
during my tenure as the deputy director
for operations
was that the agency
realized that the world was going
digital
and radio communications particularly
long range radio communications
were moving to fiber and microwave and
and cable and many other and satellites
and so we needed to modernize and i was
fortunate enough to be
the person who
uh guided that modernization so we
brought
17 000 military people who had been
doing that job overseas
at military bases in germany and japan
and
and many other places
some of which i had served at and we
brought them home
and we put them into facilities here
in the united states and we remoted
their operations to those facilities in
the united states but then we added
mission we added
satellite communications and all the
other modes of communication so that
they had a much more enriched mission
and they could do a much better job of
producing intelligence from all of the
kinds of
signals not just radio signals but
those that came from
many other sources as well that was
quite the quite the project and effort
so one other topic i do want to cover
from your background is following that
position of deputy director of
operations he then became deputy
director of the nsa from 1994 to 1997
which i mentioned in your intro is the
highest ranking civilian role at the
organization and
essentially you acted as the group's
chief operating officer i think this was
a pretty interesting time to be at the
nsa from a historical perspective given
the recent fall of the soviet union then
and a number of new threats that were
brought about by the end of the cold war
such as personal commuters you know cell
phones car based telephones and those
became much more widespread could you
talk a little bit more what some of
these new threats that were emerging
were especially at the end of the cold
war
well
you know i had worked the soviet problem
earlier i've been the head of the
organization that
targeted the soviet union so when i
became deputy director it was very clear
to me that although we weren't going to
focus on soviet union anymore because it
didn't exist anymore we were
going to have a lot of new threats
around the world
the one that bothered us the most was
terrorism osama bin laden had not
emerged yet during my tenure there
but terrorism was
increasing around the world afghanistan
was certainly becoming a center of
terrorist training there were many other
places like ethiopia of course palestine
and central africa and and so on that
were spawning terrorist threats
and so that was that was a big thing
because the communications of
terrorists were
very ethereal very very difficult to
find
first of all they didn't announce i'm a
terrorist
they you know and every one of them was
named
the same thing in their communications
so
even if they used their real names a lot
of them were named muhammad so that was
a terrific problem the languages were a
problem
all kinds of languages were involved in
the in the terrorism problem
and so it was a very difficult thing to
to deal with the other emerging problems
were the emerging nuclear threat in
other countries of the world
we already had india pakistan france
uk and a few others that we don't
mention because they won't they don't
admit that they have nuclear weapons but
we had the emerging nuclear threats in
north korea
north korea the difficulties with iran
and so on and so that became a focus of
a lot of attention again a very
difficult problem because the
communications of
the nuclear scientists and so on were
cleverly hidden
and merged into the general
communications of each of those nation
states and then there was the
missile and and all of the high-tech
weapons programs that were going on
around the world and again language
problems problems getting into
uh the depths of
their activities
were very very difficult so
a lot of tough what we call
hard targets iran was a very hard target
north korea was a very hard target and
those hard targets nevertheless were the
most important things that the u.s felt
it had to deal with during those times
i left in 1997
you recall that osama bin laden became a
real problem
in
late 98 early 99 and
and of course in 2001. so fast
forwarding today i do want to talk about
some of the current challenges that we
face in security and bill you and i have
talked about previously four key attack
factors being supply chain attacks
ransomware apts advanced persistent
threats and phishing would love for you
to dive into those four key attack
factors in more detail and then also
both ashley and colin from our class
wanted to touch upon a few related
things in terms of ashley wanting to
know a little bit more about some of the
big problems that the industry is trying
to solve perhaps i think it might be
helpful to put that in the context when
describing the four key attack vectors
and colin's also very interested in
touching upon consumer security and what
we should be doing to safeguard
ourselves in our information yeah so
by now every one of you should know what
a supply chain attack is we've been
reading about them
over the last month the most famous was
the solar winds attack which was just
revealed i can tell you from
from open sources that is commercial
sources
that the the solar winds attack the
supply chain attack involving solarwind
software began
as early as february of 2020
and wasn't discovered until december
of 2020 we still don't know how many
companies have been compromised the
numbers
range from
200 to 18 000
companies that were compromised
supply chain attacks are really
insidious essentially
the hackers or
attackers whichever
name you want to give them attack the
source
of software that's in
current use by both commercial and
and government users
and they wind their way through the
networks that serve those suppliers and
they try to find their way into the
what's called the devops
that is the
development operations where code is
being written
and
and then they make changes
to the suppliers own code the most
popular in the case of solarwinds
change being
to to essentially change the update
mechanism so that it provided updated
copies
of the software
to their customers
that allowed entry
into each customer's network and that's
a very insidious attack by the way it's
not a new attack
but it's a very insidious one and it's
it leads to the second
vector that i talked about which is apts
are the advanced persistent threats
because once you can get in then you can
begin leaving pieces of software in
place in each of the targeted companies
or government agencies
that allow you to repeatedly enter and
remove files that you want to remove or
remove emails or
or to
even go so far as to be able to deal
at the keyboard level and
capture keystrokes
so you can capture more passwords you
can extend your
your footprint within someone's networks
until you get to all the critical pieces
their r d their
software development all of the things
that are important to
companies today the
the third vector is ransomware and i i
would assume that most of you have heard
a lot about it what you haven't
probably realized is the most targeted
entities
in the united states for ransomware up
until recently were health facilities
hospitals and
and health suppliers well wellness and
health centers why
because that data is critical to them
and they can hold
it for ransom and collect pretty
pretty good numbers in their ransom but
recently it's expanded a great deal to
where it now also includes
things like government agencies and and
many other people who have critical very
confidential information
which they essentially encrypt
and hold for ransom
and you can't decrypt it unless you pay
them the ransom by the way
encryption is very effective these days
if you don't have the keys
the chances of you decrypting it or
almost nil i
i'm quoted on the internet
in a famous case that i was involved in
as saying that aes
that's the
that's the less effective form of
the advanced encryption standard would
require all of the computers
in the world
12 trillion times the age of the
universe to break one message
that's pretty powerful encryption
and so you don't break it by brute force
you have to be
more clever than that
and so ransomware is extraordinarily
effective
and finally i i would assume that every
one of you has received a phishing email
recently i receive about
10 to 15 a day they're called spear
phishing in my case because my name is
associated with a lot of companies that
are in the cyber security world
and also is associated with government
agencies that have secrets
and so they try every way in the world
to get me to click on links i just don't
like click on any links but phishing is
the most popular way
of finding your way into somebody's
network and being able to exploit it
colin ashley anything um you wanted to
ask or follow up on that
yeah i have a quick question maybe there
are a bunch of like cyber security
businesses now that
do provide like anti-phishing software
but also provide
kind of training for enterprises to to
raise awareness around fishing
i'm curious if you have any thoughts on
on those services and
whether
that's enough or maybe it's a good
starting point but
you know and and i am very
colin i have very strong feelings
you can't train your way out of the
fishing problem it's it's a problem that
every time they do a test in the
companies that don't have the training
they get about a 20 hit rate that is
about 20
percent of the people will click on a
link they should know after the training
about 15 of the people will click on a
link that they shouldn't have so we need
technical solutions and i keep looking
for companies
that have found ways to
spot phishing emails using
high performance graphics analysis using
artificial intelligence machine learning
and so on and i found a couple who were
working on that but none have perfected
it yet but i i just don't believe that
you can train your way out of the
fishing problem
that makes sense and i'll ask a really
specific question i'm curious if you're
familiar with this company called fish
me and they rebranded to coffee yes
i'm familiar with fish me
yeah they were tied up in like some
cyphus issue where the firm that
invested with them had a big russian lp
but i guess my question was
do you see that type of thing becoming
like more of an issue with government
getting more involved in companies in
the cyberspace for national security
reasons
yeah i don't believe fish fee was the
one that had russian lps i think it was
another company which is now named
co-fence
uh they they changed their name they
used to be fish me and changed it to
co-friends
yeah
well anyway your question again
regarding
yeah i guess it was around
do you think that that's sort of an
isolated situation or what do you think
about investment firms that you know
have lps from from china and russia and
other you know nation states that might
have complicated relationships with the
us do you think
those types of situations will
potentially play out more frequently
going forward or is that kind of a worn
off well i i think we have to be
concerned if there are foreign investors
who have access
to trade secrets and other confidential
information technical information in
companies that they are investing in
so the the general idea is that we
in this country
will limit foreign investment
to
a financial role only
no board seats and no no access to
non-disclosure information that's hard
to carry out and it's it
it's
you know it's not something that we
practice
as a country because we try to invest in
foreign
companies in some cases but i personally
stay out of
foreign investments either
foreign investments into my companies
are
investments in foreign companies in my
case because i figured that that's not
going to benefit either company
bill related to uh colin's question is a
question from spencer that he previously
flagged in terms of
where the u.s stands relative to china
russia north korea iran related to
cyber security and in what areas do you
think we may be
significantly behind and how do you
anticipate that the us will catch up
on that front
so i
i need to know whether the context is
offense or defense i think it's defense
i was i was thinking more so defense but
would love to kind of hear your take on
on both sides of the equation okay well
let's do the offense because there's
less i can say about it
on the offense side it's pretty well
established that the players rank in the
order of
russia
china
iran
and then somewhere in there is israel
and they might be
in the middle of that pact they might be
at the top of that back
it's hard to say
and as far as where the u.s is and
offensive capabilities sometimes it's at
the top of that heap and sometimes it's
not
it depends on the kind of attack that
you're talking about
on the defensive side our our problem is
that our problem's twofold the first is
that the the offense only has to find
one way and the defense has to find all
of the ways
and so that makes for a very unequal
equation it's like having uh
you know 50 simultaneous equations and
and and somebody gives you a hand on one
of them and so you solve it they they
have a lot of success in getting into
u.s
companies the great worry for me is how
much success they enjoy in getting into
u.s critical infrastructure
our financial systems our electrical
grid our
transportation systems
i mean they
they actually probably
know every passenger on every airplane
because those aren't protected very well
and and we could go through industry by
industry
government organization by government
organization and the answer would vary
according to which one you were talking
about
and how much effort they put into it but
if they determine that they
need
to get in they launch what are called
campaigns
and the campaigns that
iran for example launches against the
financial system because and north korea
because that's their need
they need money they need hard currency
and so that's what they go after the
russians want technology
and the chinese want technology and so
they go after the aerospace
companies and so on have you ever taken
a look at the chinese stealth fighter
if you put a picture of the chinese
stealth fighter on one side of the
screen and the
us
stealth fighter f35 on the other side of
the screen they're virtually identical
and
i once because of the winona thing that
we started out with i became very good
friends with senator moynihan
and my gift to him after the ceremony on
winona was a picture of the u.s fat boy
which was our first
atomic bomb and the russian equivalent
side by side
and each one had the u.s scientists
standing next to it the other one had a
russian scientist
standing next to it but the bombs were
virtually identical
that's the importance of
of these guys being able to hack into
our technological base because they can
copy our technology and it doesn't cost
them very much
computers are cheap
did that answer your question
spencer
yeah that was very helpful thanks so
much
so bill i do want to touch a little more
upon modern day security threats and the
changing threat landscape i love this
recent quote of yours from a podcast
where you said we have a choice in cyber
security we can continue doing things
the way we've always done them close our
eyes and hope for the best or we can
adapt to the changing threat landscape
can you elaborate a bit more about how
we need to catch up in our ability to
defend and how should we think about
applications of for instance ai and
machine learning and security with iot
yeah
we're running out of cyber security
specialists in this country
at the present moment they're somewhere
between 350 and 500 000
unfilled cyber security jobs in the
united states
and they're more than
more than a million unfilled in the
world and that number is projected to go
to well over a million by
uh 2023 in this country it's a real
crisis
so we have to
begin applying automation ai machine
learning and things that will
relieve us of the need of having so many
people doing this specialized job of
cyber security there's also a thing
called soar
which is the ability to automate all of
the responses that our sensors tell us
are in existence i'm always a little
worried about sore
because if the enemy understands how it
works very well
they can use it as a weapon they can
essentially
begin to send us signals that set our
automated systems off in a course that
is not beneficial to us so we have to be
careful about that
vulnerability assessment is really
important i'm on the board of a company
that is called cyricon they've applied
machine learning and ai
to the deep web
and what they do is they mine the deep
web for vulnerabilities that are being
discussed by
hackers
and and being exchanged in in various
irc or
or conversations and so on and they do
that in foreign languages as well
that is very very helpful because it
leads them to be able to predict
which vulnerabilities by vulnerability
class and name
are going to be used in real attacks in
short order and so their customers get
to to know get predictions about where
they should be patching their software
how they should be locking down things
in order to prevent attacks and so on so
in short you know we need to
we need to smarten the system we need to
do threat assessment we need to use
those threat assessments to guide
responses
and then we need to automate those
and on the topic of needing more
security experts in government i do want
to touch a bit upon government's role
and some comments uh from tabi melissa
and spencer in the class so tevin noted
in terms of your thoughts around
how we should think about policy keeping
up with the rate at which technology is
changing while melissa is interested in
the government's role if any and
information security and particularly
global information security and then
spencer brings up an interesting point
in terms of how should we also think
about longer dated capitals such as
family office money doing perhaps a
better job in working with the us
government on network and information
security investments so a lot of topics
you cover there bill but would love your
initial thoughts on that okay i used to
be on the
defense advance research projects agency
advisory board
and during that time i discovered that
that they were not spending any money on
cyber security at all this is an
organization that's supposed to be
helping us with technologies that are
quote over the horizon
over the horizon not on the horizon
and i talked to the director of darpa
and said
uh this is shameful she said well it's
nsa they won't they won't let us
i said well nsa is not in charge
so you should be putting money into it
and
you should be telling them where you're
putting the money so that they
don't have to put money into the same
places
and we should have a coordinated effort
they finally put money into cyber
security and a lot of it was well spent
particularly on critical infrastructure
protection so the first job of
government is to spend money on research
and to be able to bring advanced
technologies i mean a lot of people are
skeptical about the government's role in
technology
but you know we all have devices
on us today we're using them right now
that came from government programs like
vlsi
turned into the high performance chips
that we currently use in all of our
phones and computers and
everything else that we have and our
wearables as well so the first role is
technology and spending money because
they can concentrate that money on
things that are
not necessarily commercially viable at
the moment
but could become viable for commercial
applications down the road that's
happening a lot more and more the second
area that they should be in
involved in and they are now beginning
to fix the problem
is information sharing the government is
going to see in their role as
intelligence collectors and defenders of
their own organizations and agencies
they're going to see attacks
that are going to also occur in the
commercial
sector and in the critical
infrastructure sectors and they should
be sharing that information you probably
noticed that ann neuberger from nsa
recently became the national security
advisor for cyber security the new the
new head of cyber security for the white
house
is an ex-nsa person
and so that these are people who are
highly trained in both offense and
defense and they can help to guide
policy on information sharing or policy
on research and development investment
and and many other areas as well so
there's a there's a critical role for
them and i think that
we're finally getting to the point where
we're
we are letting them play out that role
in a more credible way so bill we have
about 15 minutes left now i do want to
touch upon quantum computing as well as
crypto so on the quantum computing front
what are the implications of quantum
computing on security especially being
able to break rsa and what does that
mean for guarding and encrypting data in
the future and before answering that
question would love if he could first
explain to the class a little bit more
about rsa okay well i talked about aes
earlier and how unbreakable it is
and that so you don't try and you don't
try and attack the the symmetric key
cryptography that is out there because
it's pretty damn strong
but one of the things you can attack is
the key system the keying system and
there are two ways that people
distribute keys one is by physically
distributing them in advance that's
msa's preferred method
for many many years
and the second is by using
a higher level mathematical exchange rsa
being one of the better known ways of
doing key exchange in that very large
prime numbers are used to create
a public key and a private key and the
public key is used to encrypt the
the public key of the recipient is used
to encrypt the the key that you want to
use
in your aes system and they use their
private key then to decrypt it put it
into their encryption device and be able
to software or hardware and be able to
operate an encryption system so
obviously if you could break
rsa or elliptic curve or
diffie-hellman the three primary
mathematical techniques for exchanging
keys then you would be able to get the
keys
and be able to decrypt the
communications
well up until about 15 20 years ago
that was unthinkable
because the prime numbers involved were
like 20 48
bits
long
and almost indeterminable by any
conventional computer attack
and then someone
said well
what if we had this computer that could
try everything all at once
and then we just take the answers that
work and that's called a quantum
computer and i happen to be on the board
of the entanglement institute of and of
two other companies that are doing
quantum research
so i know a fair amount about quantum
computing
i know it's very difficult we
we're not likely to see a
quantum computer built in the next year
two years five years we don't know about
10 years and then
in 15 years or 20 years it looks highly
likely so if you had that quantum
computer you essentially could break
every encryption system currently
in use on the internet
tls
uh ssl all of the ones that are used by
your banks and the
uh fintech and so it's it's a
it's a golden ring
or a brass ring whichever
uh one you want to identify it with but
it's uh it's it's a big prize
and so a lot of money is going into
quantum
computing
there's also a lot of money going into
quantum
key exchange because it turns out
that if we can't build a quantum
computer
what we do know how to do is to
exchange keys
using entanglement so that
if the
if the intended recipient
it has photons that are entangled with
the ones that you send then he can get
the key but nobody else can
because if they look at the keys then
they they no longer are entangled and
and so it will fail chinese have been
successful in doing entanglement key
exchange via satellite there are several
companies in the us that make fiber
optic key exchange systems at the
quantum level
but the big problem is quantum repeating
because fiber
destroys the entanglement in about 40
kilometers so you need to solve that
problem so there's a lot of research
going on
in quantum computing quantum repeaters
quantum radars
and quantum sensors
and it's really exciting stuff
it's also very hard science i love it
when i go to one of my companies
because there are 12 phds in that room
with me
and
it's it's a pretty exciting two days
of exchange of information
some pretty big technical challenges we
need to solve on the topic of crypto
what are some of the implications of the
rise of cryptocurrencies being used to
finance
not just software-based attacks but also
physical attacks such as kidnappings for
instance and especially given that
a lot of cryptocurrencies are well
basically the you know the key aspect is
being virtually untraceable and how that
makes catching criminals a lot harder
how should we be thinking about the rise
of crypto and um these new forms of
attacks well the first way you should
think about it is all of you are young
enough
that your if quantum computers are ever
built
you're going to see crypto currencies
collapse because they're built on
the kind of uh public private key
exchange that i was just describing
that quantum computers can break
so
they have a limited lifetime
at least theoretically and that's kind
of that makes it kind of interesting in
its own right but
the other part of it is what you
described which is the the fact that
ransomware now most of the people who
do ransomware attacks
demand that the payment of the ransom be
done in a cryptocurrency
because it is uh virtually
untraceable by the way if you ever buy
any bitcoin or ethereum or any of those
make sure you write down the password
that you use somewhere
because
it's impossible to recover your wallet
if you lose the password
and it just goes to ground it's it's
never recoverable there's no
there's no history of who bought what
for you to recover your
cryptocurrency yep some pretty sad
stories of newly minted millionaires not
being able to get their money from
crypto so one of the last questions i
want to ask you is from spencer which is
what are some next generation cyber
security products that excite you the
most
yeah i mentioned cybertron and i think
it's it's really exciting because it
gives you
an incredible insight into what the
hacking community is doing and where
they're going to focus their attention
next and how they intend to carry out
their attacks
another one is one of alsop louie's
companies called run safe it's very
interesting company
essentially their approach is to to put
to take code let's say you've got an
application
to take that application code
and transform it
uh
into a random sequence
that it understands but if you look at
it from the outside you can't understand
so the net result is that it's it's
randomizing the code to observers but it
is not randomizing it to itself
it's able to continue to execute its
role in its mission
that's pretty exciting for example a lot
of the u.s weapon systems are based on
very old code
and the cost of upgrading that code to
new operating systems
is extremely high
but with their system
you can actually obscure the the code
so that it still operates and and you
don't have to upgrade other other
applications of their stuff is in the
financial world and in the
what's called uh devsecops that is the
development of
secure applications in a automated way
so that the security
portions particularly for open source
portions of their code can be obscured
using their techniques
another company that i'm excited about
is
one that it's called seaport what it
does is it
essentially combines a com com a command
and control architecture
with a security architecture
and it does two things as a result of
that
it allows you to have
much
faster speeds in your encrypted
communications and it also provides for
agile
cryptography you can actually change the
key
for every packet that is transmitted and
received so
you can be
moving it around in terms of frequency
or channel or whatever
at the same time you are
moving it around cryptographically
changing it from aes 128 to aes
256 and and then changing the key
virtually every packet that's
that's pretty difficult for people to
work with it has one other exciting
component
it can hide in plain sight it converts
the let's say
you're running a vpn it converts the vpn
from tcpip to udp
and so it looks like all the netflix
traffic out there
and
it's pretty hard to find it if you can't
find the headers
so it's it's also an exciting company
there are others that that's just a
sample those are real startups there
there are some that are
a little more advanced that i also think
are doing really great things
thanks for sharing that bill i want to
sneak in one final question given that
we're in the middle of a pandemic how
has the recent pandemic shifted
priorities in regard to security
especially given how people are now
using zoom more often spending more time
on social media like tick tock can you
talk about if priorities have shifted
are there new potential avenues for
attacks that we should be thinking about
yeah in fact one of the newest avenues
for attacks is to attack the vpns
or the zoom
systems that people are using for
working from home i know companies that
are doing everything from
software development to team exchanges
to customer exchanges to you know
involving
non-disclosure information and trade
secrets
and so on
that are exposing the information via
uh those means the second thing is that
a lot of large companies have found that
particularly since there were there was
a an attack a
supply chain attack against one of the
big vpn companies that was discovered
within the last two weeks
that a lot of the passwords and
login credential information has been
exposed by people using vpns from home
or using them properly from home that's
one of the reasons seaport is exciting
it can essentially
hide the vpn inside a tunnel
that's a uvp tongue
and so it's very hard to break into
even a even a bad vpn gets
pretty well
pretty difficult to break into
but some of the big companies some of
the big aerospace companies have had
really terrible
break-ins that were enabled by work from
home bill thanks again for sharing your
experiences with us today you know
hasn't been since the verona project
started in 1943 but has been for several
several decades both your reflections on
the past as well as current threats that
we face in the look ahead